hello Sandra this is Tom's been speaking
be ahead of the European Bank for
Reconstruction and Development I would
take your question on what we are
specifically doing to invest in
innovation and job creation so we do in
the region for which we are created for
which is Central and Eastern Europe and
Central Asia and the bank invests
something like nine billion a year
trying to attract and successfully serve
private investments alongside and we are
committed to on one hand invest into
energy efficiency and climate change
mitigation and at the same time in
helping those countries to modernize and
diversify their real sector and with the
incentives we have with the capital we
have and with the policy dialogue we
have engaged in I think we can really
say that things change and that we
contribute to this change thank you for
listening